اختطاف ام تسليم جدل مستمر حول قضيه
يكتنفها الغموض في الكثير من تفاصيلها
فبالرغم من اعتراف حكومه بيبه بتسليم ابو
عجيل للولايات المتحده
وتاكيد واشنطن بانه قيد لاحتجاز لديها
لمحاكمته في تفجير لوكربي الا ان الاعتراف
الذي فاجا الشقيين الليبيين المنقسمين بين
حكومتين متنافستين لم يمر مرور الكرام فقد
ساهم بدوره في زياده حده غضب الشارع
الليبي للمعارضه على قرار تسليمه الى
الولايات المتحده دون سند قانونيه كما
طالب الليبيون بالافراج عن كافه السجناء
السياسيين خوفا عليهم من تلقى نفس المصير
الذي تلقاه ابو عجيله لان القضيه اغلقت
بعد ما دفع القذافي التعويضات الماليه
المطلوبه انا ذاك فكيف وصل ضابط
الاستخبارات الليبيه السابق من طرابلس
مرورا بمصرات الى واشنطن
وكاله اساسيه بريس الامريكيه نشرت تفاصيل
هذه الرحله وذلك نقلا عن اربعه مسؤولين
امنيين وحكوميين ليبيين على درايه مباشره
بعمليه الخطف
المسؤولون اكدوا على ان الامر بدا باخذه
من منزله في حي ابو سليم في العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس ثم نقل الى مركز احتجاز
يديره جهاز امن الدوله
[موسيقى]
من خلالها على تلك الاسئله التي تدور حول
دوره المزعوم في هجوم
كما ان الولايات المتحده تمارس الضغوطا
على حكومه الدبيبه لتسليمه منذ شهور وفقا
للتقرير الذي نشرته السوشيه بريس
حيث انه في كل مره يتواصل فيها الجانبان
يكون ابو عقيل على جدول الاعمال فبعد
اطلاق سراح مسعود من السجن كلثفت اداره
بيض المطالب التسليم
ورفض البيت الابيض ووزاره العدل الامريكيه
التعليق على التفاصيل الجديده بشان
التسليم كونهم يرون ان نقل مسعود تتويج
لسنوات من التعاون مع السلطات الليبيه
سلطان العربيه